خطط امريكا العسكريه سريتها خرجت عن
السيطره معلومات سربت واصبحت حديث العالم
خطط تكشف نوايا امريكا في اوكرانيا بالصور
والارقام
هذه وثيقه سريه توضح تمركز الجيشين
الاوكراني والروسي ونقطه انطلاق الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني وهذا رسم بياني للمعدات
العسكريه المنتظر وصولها لاوكرانيا وايضا
اماكن تدريب الجنود الاوكرانيين بينما هذه
الوثيقه تبين خطوط الامداد العسكري وممر
الاليات خطه الدفاعات الجويه جليه هنا
توضح الوثيقه توزيعها في اوكرانيا الشهر
القادم خريطه اخرى لموقع العمليات
المرتقبه في الجنوب الشرقي من مقاطعتي
خرسون وميكولايف ما عرضناه هو بعض من 100
وثيقه سريه سربت تباعا على وسائل التواصل
تكشف عما تخططه امريكا عسكريا في اوكرانيا
وايضا في الصين والشرق الاوسط غذاء السالم
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات